[Music]  so what are you doing out here there is  a legend in the jungles of the Amazon of  a tree that heals or it could change the  world but if it gets into the wrong  hands  he could awaken a great evil I believe  that the legend is real which was man  I'm gonna find energy wall when I do  just imagine the lives that could be  saved I've been looking for this tree  longer than anybody I've tracked the  legend every village every island  nothing be searching for something can't  be found but you've never had the key  let's do something that's safe as  go-sees develop ends there all no  elephants in the Amazon and I don't even  like elephants lady everybody likes  development  know this about the journal  everything that you see wants to kill  you and Canada  careful take a smell fear  [Music]  oh my god  [Music]  who brings a submarine to the Amazon oh  yeah  [Music]  goodnight  Oh  [Music]  run get it come on I got it  I don't got it go the way I planned  [Music]